>> THE NATIVE OF PARKLAND
FLORIDA RYAN GETZLAF WITH
THIS DEAL AND IT WAS LIFE THE .
HE WAS LATE COMING INTO THE Z
COMING LATE INTO THE ZONE.
THE DUCKS GETS A LITTLE PUCK
OF 2-1.
LUE
JACKETS OWNED.
THEY CAN'T SEEM TO GET A HANDLE
ON THE PUCK.
RYAN HENRY.
THIS WAS A MOVE WE SAW HIM GO TO
ZEGRAS.
TAKEN BACK
TREV
>> THE PASS OFFTHE BOTTOM LEFT
CIRCLE.
BACK TO THE LINE THE F F THESE
TEAMS FIRST MET IN COLUMBUS AND
AS THE SIX TIME 20 GOALSCORER
STUCK ON FIVE FOR THE SEASONON.
USUALLY PERSISTS FRIDAY
AFTER TONIGHT, THE JACKETS WILL
ITS 3-2 TWO.
>> THIS IS JUST A DEFENSIVE ZON
BREAKDOWN AGAIN.ABLE.
HE JUST MISSED A LITTLE BIT ON
THE REDIRECT.
>> LAST NIGHT, LIPSITZ ACROSS
AND GAVRIKOV GETS IT AND DEEP.
TURNOVER
THE PASSING CENTER ISIS
A 24 PASSES IT IMPAIRED WITH A
FOR SHORT PASS, GETS IT BASK
FROMAT THAT WRIST
SHOT FROM  SILLINGER
DANFORTH, JOHNSON WHO WHINES IT.
WHIPS IT BACK IN.THAT HE GOT
A GOOD ANGLE AND THE DEFENSIVE